tu comprends pas quoi pourquoi ils ont
demandé de danse avec billet alors que
c'était pas là danseuse danse avec les
maisons en fait tu voulais faire un
happning c'était un spécial prime
retrouvailles il y a 20 ans c'était
drôle que Lorie donc ils se sont dit
comme toujours tiens c'est cool ils
étaient ensemble on les rappelle mais
ils ont oublié qu'ils ont oublié que si
on est plus ensemble souvent c'est que
c'est moyen donc Lorie elle a répondu
sur Youtube allez vous faire [ __ ] mais
avec ses mots regardez
il y avait une épreuve ou les danseurs
enfin ils devaient danser avec des gens
masqués et tout le monde pensait que
c'était moi qui dansait avec Billy
et ben c'était vers moi non mais par
contre la production m'avait demandé de
venir danser voilà c'était la petite
anecdote mais bon je trouvais ça un peu
gonflé quand même
parce que parce que bon voilà quoi
mais en tout cas vous avez été vous avez
été très très drôle avec vos messages
alors on va tout vous dire mais en fait
ils ne peuvent pas se saquer mais c'est
un truc on va vous dire pourquoi oui à
l'époque quand ils ont rompu ils sont
restés deux ans ensemble dans les années
2000 à 2004 et en fait Billy avait sorti
une autobiographie dans laquelle il
parlait de Laurie et il disait à
l'époque Britney Spears c'était très à
la mode etc et j'en avais un peu marre
des chanteuses sans talents qui
faisaient toute la même chose
sympathique il faut dire aussi qu'il a
dit ça parce qu'il était énervé parce
que je crois que Lorie l'avait trompé
avec Garou Garou bah oui
il est passé à autre chose il lui a
pardonné
et du coup comme ils peuvent pas
s'attaquer mais qui s'en envoie un petit
peu babili a re répondu derrière parce
que forcément il s'en prend un petit
mais alors je peux vous faire de
l'accent parce qu'on comprend rien mais
chacun a sa vie désormais ça fait plus
de 20 ans qu'on ne s'est pas vu ni
parler je me suis concentré sur mon
travail mon métier ma vie elle aime
famille j'ai la mienne c'est très bien
comme ça si on s'est séparé c'est pas
pour rien moi c'est clair
[Musique]
quand ils ont eu un enfant respectif
chacun ils l'ont eu en même temps ils se
sont envoyés un petit message pour se
dire je suis papa et moi je suis maman
tout ça tout ça
comment tu le sais elle avait dit
L'Oréal non la question qui se trame
maintenant c'est que Billy Crawford qui
a cartonné vraiment dans cette des stars
depuis le 1er épisode quasiment il avait
gagné les gens ont trouvé très
sympathique ils dansent bien et c'est
vrai qu'il est charmant il y aurait des
petits projets autour de lui qui
pourraient arriver maintenant ben c'est
sûr et certain il a tout donné moi c'est
un retour gagnant alors pas pour une
série parce que parle pas français mais
sur un nouvel album la musique ou un
site avec des stars français je pense
que moi il va il va revenir sur le
devant de la scène mais à 100% et
d'ailleurs c'était fait pour ça je pense
que enfin la prise sous-contrat pour en
faire quelque chose c'est pour ça qu'il
l'emmenait jusque là tout compris sort
un nouvel album et dans l'oreillette
mais pas très vite qu'est-ce que tu as
dit peut-être juré ses ancien album vont
bientôt arriver sur les plateformes
digitales de musique parce que pour le
moment c'est pas autorisé eh ouais vous
me demandez les gars merci beaucoup je
raccroche ça a quand même été la pire
saison 2 de dals ça c'est retour gagnant
pour la première fois de ma vie je vous
jure j'étais chez moi avec un pote et ça
dansait et à mon avis on a pris notre
téléphone on l'a dit attends je disais
mais qui est qui attend
j'avoue que
c'est vrai
quand même un projet de fiction TF1
réfléchit avec lui
non mais quand je dis pas ça c'est pas
méchant mais c'est quand tu posais une
micro et qu'il disait ah j'ai la j'ai la
danse et fatigué machin vous comprenez
pas non mais on comprenait pas
non mais parle pas français mais comme
nous on parle pas l'anglais